♪ ♪
>> President Trump: THIS IS
ABOUT MS-13 AND WE WILL HAVE
ANOTHER ANNOUNCEMENT NEXT WEEK.
THE LEFT-WING GROUP OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE RUNNING OUR CITIES ARE
NOT DOING THE JOB THAT THEY ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE DOING >> WE ARE
GOING TO SEEK THE DEATH PENALTY
AGAINST ALEXI SANDS WHO IS THE
LEADER IN THE EASTERN DISTRICT
OF NEW YORK, A LEADER OF MS-13.
>> President Trump: FOR
DECADES, THE SINGLE BIGGEST
OBSTACLE FOR BUILDING A MODERN
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM HAS BEEN
THE MOUNTAINS AND MOUNTAINS OF
BUREAUCRATIC RED TAPE IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.
WE ARE CUTTING THE FEDERAL
PERMITTING TIMELINE FOR A MAJOR
PROJECT FROM UP TO 20 YEARS OR
MORE, HARD TO BELIEVE, DOWN TO
TWO YEARS OR LESS.
>> Bret: PRESIDENT TRUMP IN
GEORGIA TALKING INFRASTRUCTURE
AND REGULATIONS AND THEN IN THE
WHITE HOUSE GOING AFTER MS-13,
THAT HORRIBLE GROUP THAT HAS
DONE A LOT OF DAMAGE AND MURDERS
ACROSS THE U.S. GOING AFTER ITS
LEADER.
AND OF THE BREAKING NEWS AS WE
JUST REPORTED, THE NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION, ASSOCIATION OF
POLICE ORGANIZATIONS ENDORSING
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
JUST MOMENTS AGO, ITS PRESIDENT
SAID THEY GOT A CALL FROM THE
PRESIDENT THANKING THEM FOR THE
ENDORSEMENT.
REMEMBER THIS ORGANIZATION
ENDORSED PRESIDENT OBAMA AND
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN IN 2008 AND
2012 AND THEY DID MAKE AN
ENDORSEMENT IN 2016 BUT THE
PRESIDENT SAYING THAT THE
PRESIDENT SAID IT WAS AN HONOR
AND WANTED TO LET US ALL NOW HOW
IMPORTANT THIS ENDORSEMENT WAS
TO HIM PERSONALLY AND
PROFESSIONALLY.
OBVIOUSLY IT COMES AS THE
EFFORTS TO DEFUND POLICE
DEPARTMENT’S ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY ARE SPRINGING UP.
LET’S BRING IN OUR PANEL, SUSAN
PAGE.
WASHINGTON POST COMING
MARC THIESSEN AND IT SEEMS
KIMBERLY THAT THIS IS
SIGNIFICANT FOR THE PRESIDENT AT
THIS MOMENT, WHEN POLLS SHOW HIM
TRAILING IN KEY BATTLEGROUND
STATES.
THE ORGANIZATION, THE NATIONAL
POLICE ORGANIZATION IS A
SIGNIFICANT ORGANIZATION.
>> THIS IS A FUNCTION OF WHAT WE
ARE NOW SEEING IS GROWING UNREST
AND VIOLENCE.
IT’S ONE THING TO HAVE PROTEST
AND CIVIL UNREST BUT THIS IS NOW
TURNING INTO A LONG HOT SUMMER
OF VIOLENCE AND LOOTING AND
PUTTING IN A SPOTLIGHT ON THIS
QUESTION OF LAW AND ORDER AND
RULE AND THE LAW OF CITIES.
IN THE PRESIDENT IS EMBRACING
THAT.
ONE THING THAT’S INTERESTING
ABOUT THAT ENDORSEMENT AS IT
RAISES A BROADER PROSPECT OF
WHETHER OR NOT THE WHITE HOUSE
HAS SOME POTENTIAL FOR INROADS
WITH THE UNION VOTES, NOT JUST
AMONG POLICE OFFICERS BUT
FIREFIGHTERS, PEOPLE WHO WORK IN
THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND FOSSIL
FUELS BECAUSE THAT IS GOING TO
BE A BIG POINTS AND FLASH POINTS
IN CONTENTION.
>> Bret: IS GOVERNOR OF
PORTLAND ARE TALKING ABOUT
RECENT UNREST THERE.
>> THE STREET VIOLENCE IN
PORTLAND ABSENTLY NEEDS TO STOP.
THIS IS NOT THE ANSWER AS IF WE
THOUGHT, IT ONLY ESCALATES THE
TENSION.
>> President Trump: THEY ARE
LIKE WAR ZONES.
END OF THE CITY IS AND OUT OF
POLITICIANS, I DON’T SAY THIS
FOR POLITICAL REASONS, THEY ARE
ALL DEMOCRATS, LIBERAL LEFT-WING
DEMOCRATS AND IT’S ALMOST LIKE
THEY THINK THIS WILL BE THIS WAY
FOREVER.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO PUT UP WITH
THAT.
>> Bret: AT THE GOVERNOR OF
OREGON, NOT THE GOVERNOR OF
PORTLAND OBVIOUSLY.
THE GOVERNOR OF OREGON TALKING
ABOUT PORTLAND THEY ARE, SUSAN
PAGE.
WE SHOULD POINT OUT THAT
JOE BIDEN SAID THAT PUBLICLY AS
RECENTLY AS YESTERDAY THAT HE
DOES NOT SUPPORT DEFENDING
POLICE, BUT THIS IS AN ISSUE IN
DIFFERENT CITIES ESPECIALLY WITH
THE VIOLENCE CONTINUING.
>> WE SEE THE CHAOS IN PORTLAND
AND WE SEE THE VIOLENT
DEMONSTRATION THAT WE SAW IN
NEW YORK, THIS IS THE IDEAL
BACKDROP FOR THE CAMPAIGN THEME
THAT HE’S BEEN DROPPING IN THIS
WORLD AND WE SAW THIS IN A 32ND
TV AD.
BUT I THINK THE RISK TO THE
PRESIDENT, HE IS AT ODDS WITH
SOMEBODY WHEN IT COMES TO KIND
OF THINKING ABOUT RACIAL JUSTICE
JUSTICE, AND THE PROTEST, IT’S
NOT 1968 AND IN A WAY IT FEELS
LIKE HE’S RUNNING IN 1968.
>> Bret: IT WAS OVERLOOKED BY
A LOT OF THE PRESS TODAY BUT
THAT MS-13 ANNOUNCEMENT THAT THE
LEADER HAS BEEN CAPTURED AND
THEY ARE GOING AFTER THE DEATH
PENALTY, THAT’S A BIG DEAL FOR
SOME STATES THAT HAVE BEEN
DEALING WITH THAT GAME FOR A
WHILE.
>> IT IS, AND THE PRESIDENT IS
RUNNING ON "LAW & ORDER," HE’S
ALWAYS BEEN CAMPAIGNING ABOUT
TALKING ABOUT GETTING TOUGH WITH
AN MS-13 AND NOW HE’S TALKING
ABOUT GETTING TOUGH WITH THE
LOOTERS AND WRITERS IN THE
CITIES.
BY THE WAY, IN PORTLAND, THE
FEDERAL TROOPS, THE TRUMP TROOPS
AS THE GOVERNMENT CALLED AND ARE
PROTECTING FEDERAL BUILDINGS
BECAUSE THE PORTLAND POLICE ARE
DOING IT.
IT HAS BEEN $23 MILLION IN
DAMAGES TO BUILDINGS AND
PRIMITIVE.
THIS IS NOT SMALL STUFF.
THERE ARE TWO WAYS OF LOOKING AT
IT, AND ON ONE HAND THERE IS AN
ARGUMENT TO BE SAID, LET THE
CITIES BURN.
THEY HAVE WANTED TO -- THEY TALK
ABOUT DEFUNDING THE POLICE AND
WOULD LET THEM LOOK AT THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THAT LEADERSHIP.
IF THEY DON’T LIKE IT THEN WE
SHOULD DO WITH THE LEADER OF
NEW YORK DID IN THE 1990s AND
ELECTED RUDY GIULIANI TO CLEAN
THINGS UP.
ON THE OTHER HAND THE ARGUMENT
IS WHAT ABOUT THE MINORITY?
YOU CAN’T JUST LEAVE THEM
DEFENSELESS AGAINST MOB
VIOLENCE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY.
$500 MILLION OF DAMAGE IN
MINNEAPOLIS, 23 MILLION IN
PORTLAND.
THESE PEOPLE NEED TO BE DEFENDED
AND IF THEIR ELECTED LEADERS
WON’T DO IT THEN IT’S UP TO THE
PRESIDENT TO DO IT.
>> Bret: IN THE MEANTIME,
KIMBERLY, IT’S INTERESTING
BACK-AND-FORTH AT THE
WHITE HOUSE, ABOUT DR. ANTHONY
FAUCI.
PETER NAVARRO, ADVISOR TO THE
PRESIDENT, DR. FAUCI HAS A GOOD
BEDSIDE MANNER TO THE PUBLIC AND
HE HAS BEEN WRONG ABOUT
EVERYTHING I HAVE INTERACTED
WITH HIM ON.
SO WHEN YOU ASK ME WHEN I LISTEN
TO DR. FAUCI’S ADVICE, MY ANSWER
IS ONLY WITH SKEPTICISM AND
CAUTION.
IS THE PRESIDENT, DR. FAUCI, AND
THE VICE PRESIDENT TODAY.
>> President Trump: HE MADE A
STATEMENT REPRESENTING HIMSELF,
HE SHOULDN’T BE DOING THAT.
I HAVE A VERY GOOD RELATIONSHIP
WITH ANTHONY.
>> IT IS A BIT BIZARRE, I DON’T
FULLY UNDERSTAND IT.
I THINK THEY REALIZE THAT WAS
NOT A PRUDENT THING TO DO
BECAUSE IS ONLY REFLECTING
NEGATIVELY ON THEM.
I CAN’T EXPLAIN PETER NAVARRO,
HE IS AND WILL BY HIMSELF.
>> PETER FAT SHE IS A VALUED
MEMBER OF THE CORONAVIRUS
TASK FORCE, WE JUST COMPLETED
OUR LATEST MEETING TODAY AND WE
COULDN’T BE MORE GRATEFUL FOR
HIS STUDY COUNCIL.
SPIEL OF THE VICE PRESIDENT EVEN
PUT OUT OUR PICTURE OF THAT
MEETING.
KIMBERLY, YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> THE WHITE HOUSE ALSO SAID THE
NAVARRO PEACE HAD NOT BEEN
VETTED AND DIDN’T GO THROUGH THE
USUAL PROCESS, AND THAT SEEMS TO
HAVE TO BE THE CASE.
IN THIS CASE, PETER NAVARRO HAS
NOT SERVED THE WHITE HOUSE WELL.
THE PRESS AND CRITICS HAVE BEEN
ATTEMPTING TO CAUSE A IN THE
WHITE HOUSE OVER ITS PANDEMIC
RESPONSE POLICY, AND TO TRY TO
SUGGEST THAT THERE ARE ISSUES
BETWEEN OUCHI AND THE PRESIDENT
FOR MONTHS NOW.
SO WHY THEY WOULD REQUIRE THE
WHITE HOUSE TO SPEND A GOOD
PORTION OF THE DAY WERE
REPAIRING THAT DAMAGE, AND SENSE
OF THE PRESIDENT WELL.
>> Bret: SUSAN, LAST WORD.
DANCE COVINO HAD HIS OWN TWITTER
POST ABOUT DR. FAUCI, NOT JUST
PETER NAVARRO.
>> IT’S REFLECTED BUT NOT